you know it's funny all the stuff I put
out I'm motivated by that as well right
[Music]
please
[Music]
good question I wanted to know how you
learned the logistics of actually
operating the business you do a lot of
talks about what it takes to be an
entrepreneur but the actual I'm curious
about how you learn the application of
that I'd appreciate the answers thank
you mash a great question my man I'm
excited about this little concept this
is going to fill out these episodes that
are a little bit tougher for you Dirac I
like that you're hacking trying to make
your life a little bit easier
I respect your execution sebastian by
doing the way you learn operations and
the systems the logistics is by doing I
mean you could read about it you know my
dad was very entrepreneurial so he's
even more loosey-goosey than I am in a
lot of ways so that wasn't in place but
obviously a mentor can teach you but I
think when mentors are teaching you
they're teaching you the way it was
instead of the way it's about to be in
this new environment it's by doing the
actual work like D Rock's process how
long take you to edit the first daily be
two and a half days and now three hours
I mean it's doing that's how you get
great at your craft you do it's just
it's just there's it there's no
replacing experience and that's where a
lot of youngsters are there's a lot of
talent you understand the landscape up
but you don't have the experience yet
and so you've got to each it again real
patients and
those two three four years of tasting it
this work Pacific this run system and
this work distance this one does make
this work business this work assistant
so when you often surround yourself with
people that he didn't know from yes and
no the problem when you surround
yourself with people that know is they
come with that baggage but yes I do like
them coming with that baggage because
then I can watch it one of the reasons I
don't like row manage my people is
because I let them do their thing and
then I watch it and like that's silly
and then I break it so we get eighty
seven percent of the value of the tried
and true and thirteen percent of kind of
the way I see and I'm always going to
you know and you know this is a lot of
stuff we talk about we don't put a lot
of stuff there like I don't talk really
about my strategy or my brain I don't
think my how smart I am or a strategic I
am that's where I get that's where it
really shines because I'm
forward-thinking that's just my natural
state real quick let me interrupt you
before you watch there homies other
story this video right here is going to
blow your mind
that's why pop let's go only need a
dollar in my gig
what wouldn't sleep encoding tough work
o'clock in the morning stuff I hold it
onto your years I'm impressed I have a
crazy idea you and I at our best as a
team when we're just being ourselves and
just hacking there's always so much
there's such a special thing that I've
never been able to replicate right
[Music]
Gary B he rocks you to anyway
probably brother Congrats on this next
chapter of your life go crush it go kill
it
one life baby how do you just reach out
to fifteen people you've been dying to
do business with and just DMM say what
can I do for you period that's it
99.9% chance they won't answer you if
you want to reach them 4.01 it's worth
it that point oh one life
[Music]
blah
[Music]
[Music]
hello how are you very good Congrats on
winning you're welcome yeah I know so
we've got some time together how can I
help you I get it I chopped for Mia for
a second
what would upset you one more time you
think about what so look I think I think
it's about perspective right I think the
reason that I'm able to focus is that I
keep things very binary right you know
outside of the most extreme things
health of my family I try to make I try
to remind myself whether it's
friendships or back when I was fading
relationships or I put them in the
proper perspective so I think the bigger
thing for you is to is to categorize
both both the things that are going on
and put them in the proper bucket both
the studying for what you're trying to
become and questioning yourself if
that's really what you want and as as
your lack of focus at times just a
subtle indicator that you're doing this
because you think it's the right thing
to do or you were told to do this or
you've always thought you were going to
do this but now that you're here you
don't actually want to do it or do you
just value you know these relationships
or other things that are running through
your mind
even more than your career or your you
know the things that you're focused on
so I think it's being honest with
yourself that your brain and your
emotions are going in a different
direction than what you think on paper
is the thing that you're supposed to do
and I actually think you need to accept
that instead of fighting that I think
you need to question why that's
happening more so than well I need to
stay focus I've got a lot of studying to
do
to become this
you got to really break down those two
things and I think and you know what's
funny is I think you know that I think
you don't need me to tell you that it's
just you know sometimes it helps hearing
it from another voice right like I think
the thing that has always worked for me
is that it's been crystal clear for me
what I'm trying to do and and I've had
everything in the right places mentally
and then it's able it's enabled me to go
very fast which really matters so do you
agree with what I'm saying
hold on one second I hope my you stop
there's code on my page one life that
motivated you you said and it make yeah
I mean it makes you start question you
know it's very funny I'm so empathetic
to people who will let me ask you a
question the thing that you're doing
right now how much was that manifested
from you at a young age or other people
around you yeah I mean I think I think
once you know I'm glad to hear that it
came from you from a young age I would
tell you that things change and you need
to make sure you're focused on that you
know you know so you know sometimes you
have a picture of how something's going
to be and then when you get there it
doesn't live up to that and so yeah I
mean I am motivated by one life to you
know it's funny all the stuff I put out
I'm motivated by that as well right like
I challenge myself to remind myself it's
one life it's one at-bat and it rocks me
and my foundation when I think about it
as well the other thing I would tell you
and I think if you follow my stuff you
know this there's such a young woman and
I really really really hope that you
deploy patience as well right like you
know you can you can you cannot have it
perfectly clique for ten years and still
be young and I think a lot of people
forget that you know for me early in my
career with my great ambitions building
a liquor store a wine store you know
didn't seem on paper like this is what's
going to help me get to all these places
that I want to be but it was building a
foundation in my 20s and early 30s that
allowed me to build on top of and I
still at 41 view myself extremely young
so keep that in mind as well I think
that helps you're welcome I hope you
have a great day and feel free to reach
out to me on email if I can help horn
you're welcome good to see you too back
my son
your access questions we turn it down
[Music]